i seen an interview on youtube the other
day one done did you have something
similar and said would you rather kill
your mum
or um give brains to a guy
and he said he's his ultimatum was is
the guy nutting in his mouth
and the guy said yeah he's not in your
mouth he's out killed my mom
he'd rather kill his mother than have a
don nut in his mouth
oh wow so wait okay
would you same scenario but would you
rather
let a guy ejaculate in your mouth or
suck him off to it for him to ejaculate
would i rather
not like okay in that scenario what did
he give him
did he give him an option nah he just
said yeah he said you have to suck him
up
yeah he said he said that it started off
with sucking off
would you rather suck off a breath or
have your mom killed
and then the guy said is he not in my
mouth okay okay p another pick your
poison off the bat would you rather
have to suck a guy off he doesn't have
to knock your mouth or
he bashes in your mouth like he not he
wants until you not see him off you
don't have to touch his dick whatsoever
you're just there like a dog
tongue out i'd rather say that one you
take that one 100 100 percent
100 percent you just did like so
i'll just wait there i would i would do
it i'll close my eyes and wait whatever
you're waiting for after and you
and you peek he will take your eye off
fam
i'd much rather that than what then
caress man's tool
until he says stop no way imagine he
shakes
he would shake he'll be breathing and
panning nah
nah and the thing is this is ah
this is the actual question yeah answer
with honestly this is patreon okay
okay honesty no it's not getting out
it's not getting out it's not getting
out of the masses answered with honesty
ask me the question because you know
what i'm going to hate
you know i'm going to hate you already
so honestly
it's one of them was like ah you have to
actually put yourself there
unfortunately mentally you have to put
yourself there
okay okay and so if you had to suck them
off yes
just from your life's work anything you
know about sex
is all it's always been about
getting from a to b okay getting someone
to finish yes you know right
if you're giving head to a girl whether
you're getting head whether you're
[ __ ] a girl whether you're wanting
yourself off
it's all about getting from to the nut
yeah
and obviously that requires certain
manipulations yeah and speed and tempos
and rhythms and stuff like that yeah so
donny said obviously you have to suck
him off but you don't he he
he doesn't have to not in your mouth
it's just suck off until he says stop
do you think instinctively while you're
sucking him off
as you hear his pleasure rhythm going up
and down do you think he's stick to
dudley that you'll react to it
[Laughter]
so when a man's just there like oh and
you know okay
[Laughter]
that's hilarious or it's just like
do you think you'd just be like and just
slow temperatures
obviously like you said i have to
mentally put myself there so
as i'm mentally here right now i can
confidently answer that no i wouldn't
i wouldn't react enhance these pleasures
these pleasure senses do you know what i
mean
but i don't i'm not there do you know
what i mean i'm not there
but right now i can completely say i
wouldn't do it yeah